The other day I went to this restaurant,
and I ran into an old friend of mine in the bathroom.
(gasps) Oh my god, how are you?
Oh, you look so pretty!
I don't..feel pretty.
And it was like: What?
(chuckles nervously) Are you serious?
You're not joking? I mean...
Are you, are you looking at that?
And it just made me really think
about how constantly bombarded we are
with this desire to look good.
I mean, it's a message
perpetuated by TV--
BE PRETTY!
Magazines...
Billboards...
BE PRETTY!
Everywhere!
It's so hard to feel pretty when you look at that.
It is so hard to feel good enough
even though you are.
I think "pretty" is a mindset.
And I think that mindset
can be achieved by
putting in a little effort here and there,
and with a lot of self acceptance.
I'm not talking about going out
and dressing like a bedazzled gypsy.
(Unless you feel pretty
like a bedazzled gypsy, in which case, go ahead.)
But, by finding little accents
here and there
that make you feel like yourself,
with the volume on full blast!
Like, I've only gotten my nails done
3 times in my life,
but every single time,
the way I carry my arms
and my hands drastically changes.
Like, anytime I hold something, my pinky's up.
I do a lot more like, hands to my face~
And it just makes me feel like
1000 times more feminine.
But above all else, most importantly,
please, just let yourself feel pretty.
There's nothing wrong with loving your body
and loving the way you look.
Because feeling beautiful is having more confidence,
is taking more risks, is going out and being friendlier
and having a better life,
because you'll have a different attitude
and a different perspective on the world.
And it starts with loving yourself first.
Well, there you go!
Lesson of the week! Yeah!
Revelations! Okay. (laughs)
I'm actually really excited for this next week.
Um, cause I'm directing the
first short I wrote tomorrow. Ahhhh!
I always do these kind of videos in my room by myself
in my house. You know, there's no one else...
but with the short, I have to assemble a crew
and then I have to cast, get props, rent locations,
it's just...whoa! And I also forgot how
expensive that stuff is.
So I talked to Audible, who so kindly decided
to sponsor today's episode.
You can go to audible.com/anna
for a free book of your choice.
They have over 150,000 titles to choose from.
And if you're like me and you live in L.A.,
I always listen to Podcasts or audiobooks in the car
instead of listening to the same radio songs
over and over and over again.
I've been listening to Joy Land, by Stephen King.
Cause I love Stephen King.
And everything he writes is, oh, so good.
And, uh, that is audible.com/anna
if you'd like to go there.
I'll see you next week.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara